peter bertrand donc vous restez avec
nous pour en parler stanislas françois
avocat au barreau de paris nous a
rejoint pour la partie peut-être plus
juridique
stanislas françois merci de nous avoir
rejoints en direct sur rt france les
plis stop&go vite il va être donc prêtre
a priori le 2 juin
une bonne nouvelle pour le juriste que
vous êtes ou vous êtes plutôt méfiants
sinon c'est bien au barreau de lyon je
suis un peu méfiant nouvelle je demande
à voir
moi ce que vous avez l'interrogé sur
cette application c'est de quoi avons
nous besoin aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin d'un de
tests qu'ils soient généralisés donc une
campagne de dépistage massive et puis
l'autre côté on a besoin de masques donc
il ne faudrait pas que le recours à cet
outil qui serait l'application stocks au
vide
elle va soit un espèce de contre-feux
qui s'est allumé pour pallier les
défaillances originel dans le cadre de
la lutte contre cette épidémie la
défaillance originel sur le sur les
tests et les masses donc ne voyons pas
non plus dans l'application stop
qu'ovide un outil miracle et qui
permettrait de lutter efficacement
contre contre l'épidémie moi je rappelle
ce que disait le premier ministre lors
de son allocution à l'assemblée
nationale gratuite avec dernier
lorsqu'il a présenté en seniors présenté
le plan des confirmands le premier
ministre nous a dit il a d'entrée de jeu
a écarté cette ce sujet sur
l'application la star kobe dans dix ans
que compte tenu des incertitudes sur
cette application est bien qu'il était
bien en peine de savoir comment elle
fonctionne et comment est susceptible
d'être
après éléments non juristes de
nombreuses questions se posent sur la
protection des données personnelles
il a la garantie des libertés publiques
tout à fait alors qu'en pense le docteur
le grand parce que on a vu un petit peu
plus tôt dans le journal il y avait
l'exemple islandais ou le tracking et
racing semblait plutôt avoir de bons
résultats on a vu aussi que c'était le
cas en allemagne en corée du sud on
taiwan est ce que c'est un outil qui
vous semblent indispensables docteur
laurent nys ans dont ma fille 8% de test
donc on fait feu contesté 10% +3 la
course en test sur une population
vous pouvez faire du trafic ça va pas
changer des mâts de choses ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que nous avons un test
qui a une sensibilité n'est pas bonne ce
qui veut dire que plus on concentre les
champions que l'on va tester et puis
nous allons produire des faux négatifs
que nous avons libéré dans la nature
c'est juste le théorème de balès c'est
quelque chose qu'on apprend prévient
anne destine donc du coup concentrait la
population tft n'est pas une bonne idée
a la bonne idée c'est justement de
tester un grand nombre de personnes
c'est juste fini dans son attitude mais
docteur tout simplement les tests et le
tracking est ce que ce nom pas ce ne
sont pas deux outils finalement qui ont
besoin l'un de l'autre on a vu que ça a
été le cas très tôt en allemagne on a
testé 13 en aimant et ensuite on a isolé
et on a tracé les gens finalement pour
pas qu'ils se rencontrent pour les
lisent les isoler est ce que l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre finalement pour une
efficacité maximale alors pour être très
clair il faut isoler systématiquement
toute personne qui est suspecte de que
lille sans la tester c'est à dire sur le
diagnostic du médecin est une personne
qui serait dans un groupe
contact
vous pouvez tester si la fantomatique
par contre si les phares automatique
elle n'a aucun sens d'être testé et si
on se concentre uniquement sur lesquels
contacts à ce moment là on va entraîner
une augmentation de la concentration des
champions et on va augmenter le nombre
de faux négatifs que l'on va relâcher
dans la nature donc par définition même
chercher une augmentation de la
concentration du test est une erreur il
faut tester en population générale selon
les heures en général c'est de proposer
à tous stanis 80 soit vous évoquez vos
craintes concernant les libertés
individuelles
avec cette application en quoi ça
pourrait être un problème que l'état
garde finalement les des données qui
sont supposés de personnel c'est ce qui
vous inquiète le plus en tant que
juriste
oui bah c'est de toute façon c'est une
application qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la protection des données
personnelles
déjà deux se tenait dans les cimes
isolant pour également général d'
approprié question des données mais
peut-être qu'il est défini par le
parlement européen
donc c'est la possibilité de devoir
transmettre à l'état notamment des
données sensibles pour une utilisation
sont aujourd'hui on ne mesure pas les
effets se pose la question de savoir
qu'est ce que l'état pouvait bien faire
le choix de cette période de
déconfinement s'est passé qu'est-ce que
cet outil aurait vocation à perdurer
parce que doit être utilisé jusqu'à la
fin de mes fin de l'épidémie
c'est pas qu'il connaît pas aujourd'hui
le terme de l'utilisation on peut
craindre aussi des dérivations les
libertés publiques parce que c'est qu'il
m'a utilisé constitue un moyen de
de surveillance donc se pose aussi le
problème de cette application à coudre à
l'efficacité ce cas la morale et
l'efficacité scientifique pour résoudre
la crise du corps à des virus efficacité
scientifique parce qu'ici se pose la
question du consentement qui est
indispensable c'est un outil qui ne peut
être utilisé que sur la base du
volontariat rebond à partir du moment où
seuls des utilisateurs volontaires
l'utilisent
on peut en douter de son efficacité
parce que ça veut dire qu'il peut par
définition pas être généralisée ce qui
m'inquiète ce qu'ils peuvent inquiéter
bessan durée c'est à la fois la réalité
consentement et puis d'autre part sa
sincérité
parce qu'ici on est dans un climat
autour du cobra n'avait jusqu'à présent
la république nous a parlé de guerre on
a l'impression qu'on joue un peu sur les
peurs et peut on concourt à une sorte
d'hystérie planétaire autour de cette
question qui crée un climat anxiogène
qui irait à la tv finalement la
sincérité du consentement mois cet égard
j'ai une phrase du secrétaire d'état au
numérique qui nous dit que chacun pourra
refuser ces outils pour des raisons
philosophiques mais cela reviendrait
dans ce cas accepter un risque
significatif de malades et les morts
supplémentaires donc ici on donne la
possibilité de refuser évidemment
l'application mais on fait peser sur les
l'utilisateur réfractaires bien une
sorte de culpabilisation qui pourrait
altérer la réalité et la sincérité de
son consentement à l'utilisation de en
tout cas doit se prononcer fin mai
docteur la dernière question pour vous
on a entendu les craintes du juriste ça
pose effectivement le la question du
secret médical vous vos patients est ce
qu on vous en avait déjà parlé avec eux
de cette application à ce que vous les
sentez plus tôt qu'on s'entend avec un
ce consentement éclairé
justement est bien vite et quand le cid
est arrivé en france
les patients étaient consentants pour
entrer dans un fichier et les médecins
ont refusé de faire ce fichier
on a proposé votre secret médical pour l
idée ça
depuis les choses ne semblent ne pas
avoir beaucoup changé c'est à dire que
les patients seraient prêts à rompre le
secret médical pour ça mais cette fois
ci c'est un petit peu plus grave que
dans les années 80 en demande carrément
aux médecins de dénoncer non seulement
leurs patients mais de dénoncer aussi
les contacts qui ne sont pas leurs
patients dans la même application
et le tout pour une efficacité qui comme
jouer l'extérieur est tout à fait
douteuse et en dehors du fait qu'elle
est très douteuse de par le texte en
lui-même
elle était aussi douteuse dans son
application c'est à dire que 525 milles
qu'à contacter par semaine ça fait
vingt-cinq contact de ces personnes qui
sont des contacts de contact vous êtes à
7 millions de personnes
on est déjà un population réelle ça n'a
plus aucun sens vous allez mettre 23
noms de personnes qu'ils sont ni médecin
ni l'infirmier qui sont soumis à aucune
déontologie qui parfois sont hôtesses de
l'air pour aller rendre visite à des
malades vont alors faire un test invasif
on va enfoncer quand même un coton tige
dans la narine avec des risques qu'ils
sont quand même pas négligeable ni pour
la personne qui le fait unis pour les
personnes qui le subissent et tout ça
sans aucune référence à la déontologie
médicale
depuis quand quel est le cui d'art de
faire un acte médical
ces nouveaux enfin je ne sais pas c'est
un truc nouveau en france
merci en tout cas tous les deux docteurs
bertrand et stanislas françois avocat au
barreau de lyon merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct avec nous